good afternoon everybody
welcome back uh when there's a strange
occurrence i usually get to take the
podium so
this is a strange occurrence uh for
students if you don't have access to
blackboard
or if you haven't had access to
blackboard after this session just
double check that you do
if you don't then email me or the help
desk
to get that figured out because you need
to get it
to get the paper assignment okay our
speaker
for this afternoon had to uh abruptly
cancel and so
we taped him over zoom uh and we're
gonna play that for you
his presentation so i'll introduce him
briefly and then we'll go ahead and
watch that
thomas w hazlett is the hugh h mcauley
endowed professor
of economics at clemson university where
he also directs the information economy
project
he previously served as chief economist
of the u.s federal communications
commission
and in faculty positions at the
university of county of
california davis the wharton school and
george mason university
in 2019 he was awarded a jefferson
science fellowship by the national
academy of science
his papers have appeared in numerous
research journals
including the journal of law and
economics the rand journal of economics
the journal of financial economics and
the university of
pennsylvania law review and he has
written popular articles for the wall
street journal the economist new york
times
businessweek and others he is the author
of multiple books
including most recently the political
spectrum the tumultuous liberation of
wireless technology from herbert hoover
to the smartphone
uh please pretend we're welcoming thomas
w
hazlett hello
uh i am delighted to be with you today
uh if
virtually and it is a great honor to be
um uh invited to deliver a lecture
at uh the famous hillsdale college it's
an institution that takes
ideas seriously and has really added to
the richness
and diversity and deepness of american
thinking so
from the days of uh abolitionism
uh to uh the world today advocating
free markets and free minds i think that
um
the the reputation of hillsdale
is well deserved um and as much as it's
nice to be with you virtually i do hope
that there will be a
uh time to uh be with you in person
and um i get to actually visit
um the uh
the the the great institution itself so
thank you
um and uh today i plan to talk about
this robust debate
that may put me in um peculiar
historical circumstances
uh to be um awarded the opportunity
uh to give a uh a lecture um
which has been titled by the university
uh as opposing regulation in a market
and to be booed for it and we'll see
we'll see how it goes
but uh the uh the sharp debate that is
now taking place
over regulating social media platforms
and the internet giants generally
is is fascinating in many respects
historically
there's been a long debate and much much
experimentation
in how we approach our view towards
large corporate enterprise
and um now we see of course uh
political uh alliances shifting and uh
strange bedfellows
uh coming to the fore of the political
world
um so um i uh
in in putting this talk together and i'm
going to switch right now to uh
screen share is that possible here
there we go
uh in putting today's talk together uh
i just say that is my email address for
those of you who are
uh going to be um
highly supportive or highly critical or
anything in between
of the comments i make please uh please
take the opportunity to send me a note
at hazellit at clemson.edu
but in uh putting together together
today's lecture
i thought about um spending a little
time on the
neo brandeisians and uh this is from an
article i wrote last year in reason
magazine
about the interesting coalition left and
right
coming for big tech in the form of a new
trust buster movement
reprised um in the um the shadow of an
old trust buster movement
uh for which uh the late uh supreme
court justice lewis brandeis has given
more credit than any other and and
the new movement sometimes called
hipster antitrust
uh actually is touted by the advocates
themselves as a neo-brandisian movement
and it's really quite a curious public
policy that's developed
and you can take it from the president
united states himself
uh who um just recently touted a year
ago
the european union is suing all of them
well we should be doing this there are
companies i thought it was a
a rather stunning political argument
either from the standpoint of free
markets or the standpoint
of american national interests
the idea that there are companies has
always led
every administration of any political
party
to take some proprietary interest in the
success
both domestically and internationally of
large
u.s platforms that serve the world we've
seemed
gone in a different direction here and
in fact the strange bell
bedfellows can be captured by the
comments
of fox news talker tucker carlson
who came to the views to share the views
of president trump in this instance via
a lecture delivered by
professor elizabeth warren now when she
was running for president
she announced pre-trial anti-trust
verdicts
she was already in favor of busting up
amazon apple google and facebook
policy no more formally as divestiture
but
no evidence was needed none none
whatsoever
beyond what was already available in the
public domain and carlson simply said
that
warren's plan for economic patriotism
made her policy prescriptions
her policy prescriptions making obvious
sense
warren sounds like trump at his best so
this
interesting convergence has been much
commented on and
um i'm just going to take it a sort of
background for what we're going to talk
about today is it wise to regulate
the tech platforms particularly the
social media
services in ways that are much more
aggressive and different
than contemporary law would allow
i think that this is uh for the most
part a step in a
very wrong direction with negative
consequences
for the u.s economy innovation
competitiveness
and us consumers in fact louis brandeis
uh did many great things in his life
certainly accomplished many great things
was certainly um a a a legal genius
in many dimensions and at the same time
his anti-trust policies
were not accepted
well have not been accepted in the
current world
and while they did have some success and
some notoriety particularly during the
new deal
the fact is that brandeis suggested
extremely anti-consumer
anti-competitive policies okay and it
it just just a simple sample which i
talk about in my article
uh goes back to when he was testifying
in congress in 1915
and a congressman um
was was surprised that uh brandeis
noted that volume discounts were fraught
with very great evil and should be
banned
even a hundred years ago volume
discounts were obviously
uh part of the landscape and uh were as
old as
business itself wrote thomas macron his
pulitzer prize-winning prophets of
regulation
barkley could not believe he had heard
brandeis correctly
well the congressman had heard him
correctly
brandeis was simply against discounts
discounts yielded by efficiency brandeis
condemned the consumer
however for not realizing this
the consumer was servile self-indulgent
indolent
and ignorant because she would likely
shop for lower prices
in higher quality without concern for
what brandeis believed
the social ramifications and those were
the competition
was more difficult for high cost firms
that could not deliver the efficiencies
that were now being revealed
in part then because of the great
advances in technology
and business models rendered and
delivered
by the industrial revolution today we're
in another
industrial revolution some call it the
post-industrial
revolution or the new tech world and in
fact great efficiencies that allow
economies of scale and scope to serve
customer interests
at a much lower price and with much
higher quality
are being uh also brought into
doubt and scrutinized as though
maybe they should be blocked by law
now i would refer you to the article i
wrote
last year i also did submit testimony as
requested to the house judiciary
committee this last spring they've
recently issued a report the democratic
house has a very aggressive
uh and um somewhat called
uh wild-eyed plan it's not well
specified i'm not
um it's it's not the final step but it's
sort of the opening
uh shot from congress to
change fundamentally change the u.s
anti-trust laws
that report came out last month and um
my my paper is available for those who
would like to
to read my my view of what the policy
situation is there
but i'm not going to spend too much time
on that right here not the pure
anti-trust of amazon or google
or apple uh there are many efficiencies
that are in the marketplace that have
actually rebounded to the the benefit of
american competitiveness
uh to innovation in our evolving uh
marketplace and in fact delivered
tremendous consumer
gains but more specific right now
is the uh particular question
of how debate takes place on the stage
in the media and this of course is
something that's keenly important
in every year particularly a political
year a year of an important national
election
and um
i don't i wouldn't anticipate having
much of a debate with those at hillsdale
college today
uh were we alive and in person
uh i think that the the standard
reference on uh media bias in the united
states in recent years has been
delivered by an excellent economist
tim grossclose who wrote a 2012 book
called left turn and
i recommend it to all tim is
an economist of some renowned he was at
ucla when he wrote the book
he then uh moved to george mason
university in fact
uh he moved to george mason just as i
was moving from george mason
to clemson university in 2014.
indeed i believe he took my slot and i
told my my colleagues at george mason
that they got a significant upgrade
anyway it's a fine work it shows
systematically
uh how with with using standard
metrics supplied by
technical proficient technical experts
in political science
how the the political pitch
of various news outlets can be evaluated
and it does it does an excellent job of
documenting the case yes
uh liberal media bias um is a thing
and um the question now is as we
look forward to the marketplace the
media marketplace of the future
is their social media bias because of
course we're in a very serious
technological transition from broadcast
radio and television daily newspapers
and the old forms of media
we are now into social media
by which we mean the internet and uh
the great new and very exciting range of
possibilities
that has been afforded again by the
influx and application
of tremendous economies of scale given
economic
progress and the entrepreneurship of
of of capitalist enterprise so
um what what we are here is that we do
see
uh that the media companies have been
put together
to compete with and in some uh
viewpoints
uh replace the media outlets of the past
have become uh particularly biased and
biased even in a more dangerous way
than the platforms of old and there are
many
many uh many ways we can talk about
uh the sensational aspects of this uh
particularly where conservatives think
that they have gotten a raw deal by the
way there's a very lengthy list
of where people on the left believe that
they have gotten a wrong deal
but uh this is what i'll just uh focus
on very briefly i mean the new york post
uh report on hunter biden's laptop was
uh
discriminated against and uh not not
uh not declared to be fake news or to be
banned but in fact it was set aside
during a political campaign
uh as as though it were
unverified when in fact of course
unverified stories or stories that are
still being reported or stories that
will develop over time can
can and should be the subject of
of news and political debate during a
campaign
president trump's tweets have been
labeled and in some cases
that that not only flags them it makes
them more difficult
to access and as the president united
states with his own
uh viewpoints um certainly
it is the custom and expectation of
americans
that political discourse will be allowed
in interpreting first amendment freedoms
and first amendment freedoms
particularly obtained to
those involving government actions yes
uh political speech particularly by
political actors like presidents of the
united states
is afforded a very high level of
protection
and uh censorship is
is almost inevitably set aside and so
this seems to be
really violating the norms violating the
expectations
that we have had and i will allow you to
insert any blocking
story any labeling story any uh kind of
um perceived bias of the social media
there are many of them
i'm not particularly uh shocked by it
silicon valley
has long expressed certain political
preferences
in the um uh the people who work and and
have
uh internal policies at the the various
uh firms
uh we've you know we've seen much
internal dissent
at companies based upon their political
bias
and this is as per their own employees
uh saying that
their right to have dissenting views uh
has been
foreclosed and uh if you actually look
in this last election the reports are
uh that the vast majority of campaign
contributions from silicon valley
employees and executives
uh went to democratic party campaigns uh
this this was actually stunning to me
even though i had
i had expected something on the order of
90 the the fact that it's uh
very close to 100 percent um really
makes you stop and think about
you know exactly how one industry gets
to be
um you know as is as complicated and as
seemingly diverse
as that industry must be in some context
how it can be so uniform
in another and that um maybe a failing
of silicon valley may also
be a failing of the republican party uh
but many people
are led to believe right now that it's a
failing of our social structure
and in fact the legal platform on which
these social media platforms sit
should we change the rules and in fact
the discussion
in most instances comes right to this
question
why not revoke section 230. well what is
section 230 it comes from the 1996
telecommunications act
a bipartisan measure authored and passed
by the republican congress
signed by a democratic president section
230
protects online platforms from liability
from lawsuits
when they moderate moderate content in
good faith
well where did that come from well there
was a concern specifically
that companies would go into the
marketplace and they would offer
user generated content that's a a
platform like youtube
uh where people post literally millions
of videos every day
and um or it's a platform like facebook
where people post
literally millions of news stories or
uh personal uh
commentary every day so massive
content coming in not supplied directly
by the platform but aggregated and
promoted
and made easy to access for
literally billions of people around the
world and in this
rich and complicated uh
massive content uh law enforcement in
particular
wanted certain forms of very anti-social
communications
uh to be set aside and they wanted not
only
to make illegal uh
content uh including all forms of
pornography
uh they wanted to make some things that
were dubious or
close to the line uh whether it be this
kind of um
anti-social activity or terrorist
communications or
advocacy for uh extremist groups
that would um be of concern again to law
enforcement
so um there wanted to be some help
from the private platforms to eliminate
uh some of the content that was not
easily identified
uh as illegal by law enforcement itself
and so it gave
this extra incentive for a platform
to moderate or curate not just to become
an open platform everything goes
the risk of course was that the
publisher excuse me the platform would
become a publisher
as soon as it started
curating some content and editing as it
were
it would become liable for what remained
and therefore there would be a hailstorm
of lawsuits
this would uh discourage free speech and
so to encourage free speech
and this user-generated content in other
words
the flourishing of these new platforms
section 230
again became a bipartisan approach
this is the actual language i'll just
emphasize that it was specifically
and explicitly to promote good samaritan
blocking
in screening of offensive materials
including obscene
lewd lascivious filthy excessively
violent harassing and otherwise
objectionable uh material even when
it is legal meaning constitutionally
protected
so yes the publishers might have
liability
for doing this without 230 that is to
say editing
and providing some some help to their
readers in terms of what content they're
getting
but what will it do sorry what will it
do
what will it do in terms of actual
lawsuits
that will come the publisher's way well
they might be subject to
defamation suits or slander suits
in some cases invasion of privacy might
be posted because they're allowing
uh you know some people on their on on
their site
um are are posting information that
shouldn't be there about other
individuals
or they're allowing people to post about
um
criminal activities uh or assisting
selling
selling selling people perhaps firearms
that are used
in the commission of a crime that's one
of the issues that's come up
should the platforms be
liable for this the post office is a
common carrier of course it's not liable
if you send send a solicitation in the
mail
for some illegal activity there are
other laws however that of course make
it criminally illegal to use that
platform for that purpose
but that is not the responsibility per
se of the platform
so there is lively debate how much
liability
uh you know would change the internet if
in fact we took away 230 and how many
lawsuits there be i mean
uh the the standard view in silicon
valley is that this would be a big
problem that there would be
a difficulty in providing open platforms
with masses of user content
that has to be more finely curated
by platforms that can be publishers
and um that would lead to a lot more
restrictions
a lot more rejections a lot more
bannings
a lot more conservatism on the part of
the platforms
to try to again limit their liability
so the
problem we have in talking about this as
a solution
to the liberal bias element is that the
publishers
as publishers have no liability for bias
that is to say
we can strip away the protections of the
of the internet platforms facebook
twitter
google etc and yet the publishers can
still curate
or moderate as i say it's likely they
will have
incentives to moderate more and curate
more and to block
additional content but they would not
have to be left
with a politically neutral or a
viewpoint neutral product
because the government does not have the
ability to limit
the first amendment rights of
publishers as publishers so
think newspapers newspapers have bias
the new york times has a bias the
washington times
has a bias it is clear that when we know
the publication's name
we know where the editors will be coming
from
that is perfectly legal in fact it's
protected first amendment right
to move the internet platforms
into the publishing world would have
some consequences
and some incentives for them to change
their behavior
but it would not leave them with an
incentive to have politically
neutral content or to have conservatives
get more of their content published
there is no public interest license to
be a website
there is no regular authority of the of
the us
government over an internet speaker
and that internet speaker might be a
publisher
if section 230 is eliminated okay that's
what we're doing here now
um go back
there we nope where did this go
okay so here wrong order you already saw
the punch line
uh surprisingly the president united
states
did tweet this and now i'm going to fact
check it
he says twitter is out of control made
possible through the government gift of
section 230.
well that's um that's not exactly right
he's talking about the bias
of the editorial function at twitter and
yes twitter is out of control and
um that's not made possible through the
gift
of section 230 it's made possible
by the gift of the bill of rights it's
beyond control for a publisher
a publisher
to have their freedom of speech
abridged okay so the
free press
and freedom of speech
that is what's protecting twitter's
right to be biased
okay so yes there is a licensing
function
i should go back to the previous sorry
sorry to be out of order yes there is a
licensing
there is a public interest license for
for
website content in cuba
i'm happy to say that since the passing
of fidel castro that's changing
they're actually trying to get into the
modern
modern era and catch up
with capitalist countries that have
robust public debate
over the internet now they're not trying
that hard it's going slowly and
painfully
uh so don't get too excited about this
but the fact is that the stalinist
policies instituted under castro were to
allow no website
without a public interest determination
that that content was appropriate
and that is what the united states
rejects
and that is what we're pointing to
when we say the united states leads the
world
in internet innovation
now as strong an argument as that is
and i think it's overwhelming people are
thinking
in one form or another about a fairness
doctrine for the internet and this comes
through
in uh in in the arguments that the
internet platforms are not being fair
and in fact are not
being neutral and this was the context
in which the fairness doctrine was
developed
literally from 1927
under the radio act of 1927
to 1987 when there was a
reagan era deregulation
through the federal communications
commission
to end the licensing requirement for
radio and television stations
to in fact give us two-sided viewpoints
from balanced perspectives
on issues of importance to the local
communities in which they broadcast
now this story is contained in my 2017
book from yale university press the
political spectrum
the tumultuous liberation of wireless
technology from herbert hoover to the
smartphone
yes it is available on amazon i want to
note that
it explains something that should be a
prelude to the discussion of content
regulation
for media platforms today since 1927
there has been
an ability through public interest
licensing
to actually reject radio or television
broadcasting rights which are publishing
rights through the electronic media
which in fact did not deliver
fairness or equitable treatment
of opposing sides in political debates
and that policy was disastrous not only
did the spectrum allocation scheme
allow regulators to kill new
technologies
i mean there's one chapter in the book
the 30 years war
uh how long it took regulators at the
federal communication commission to
allow cellular to allow the mobile
phones that now
really access access the internet for
all of us
we had traditional rules including the
equal time rule
saying that a radio station then a tv
station
could not have a candidate for public
office on without giving equal time
to the other candidate this actually
eliminated
televised debates televised debates did
not take place for years
because of the equal time rule the fact
was that there are
30 or 40 political parties in the united
states
and every one of their presidential
candidates would have to appear on the
stage
with the democratic and republican with
the major
party candidates if in fact such
an equal time rule were enforced the
reason we got a debate in 1960
was a congressional statute that
temporarily set aside the equal time
rule
we didn't get one in 64 because there
was no set aside
the reason being by the way lyndon
johnson as president thought he had a
big lead and didn't want
uh to allow congress to to give him the
debate he didn't need it
we ended up actually going
several cycles until 1976 without
another debate and then finally in
recent decades
we've gone to a new system that
overrules by statute the equal
time rule allowing the democrat and
republican
to violate the equal time rule by
debating themselves
otherwise there'd be no debates at all
now the fairness doctrine itself was an
interesting
uh was an interesting approach where in
fact licenses for radio or television
stations would not be renewed if they
were thought to be
too one-sided or to give the viewpoint
of the owners that was said to be
propaganda radio
interestingly this was used against both
sides
originally in the 1920s policies were
used through radio licensing to kill
left-wing stations including those owned
by the
chicago federation of labor and uh
the socialists who had supported w
excuse me
had supported wevd but eugene v
devs as the station was named for the
socialist candidate for president
and requirements imposed to do equal
time
essentially through uh non-political or
non-partisan news but through
choice of subjects and the kinds of
speakers they would have
those were onerous and simply move those
stations
out of the controversy business
now more recently in the 1960s
the kennedy johnson administration went
on a campaign
a political campaign to file fairness
doctrine complaints against
radio stations around the country that
aired right-wing commentary particularly
that that was
critical of the nuclear test man treaty
that the kennedy administration
had had signed with the soviets and uh
the
um conservatives like reverend norris
who in a little tiny radio station in
red lion pennsylvania
were actually prosecuted a supreme court
case red lion 1969
found that the it was okay to have a
fairness doctrine
that could force these stations to give
free equal time to people
who had different viewpoints now the
democrats understood exactly how that
worked
but the point was not to get for equal
time and have an open debate but
the point was to force free equal time
on your political opponents
and to tax the controversy that you
didn't like
to harass and intimidate that phrase is
actually from testimony given by a
democratic
party operative when the scheme was was
revealed much later much after the fact
and much after the
united states supreme court had decided
a case not
knowing that what this was all about was
actually
a chilling effect an intentional
chilling effect of political opponents
violating the first amendment
the supreme court did not find that the
fairness doctrine in 1969 violated
the first amendment even when saying if
we could find a chilling effect of
course that would be a different matter
well they missed it in the very case
that they examined
and this exactly has been what this kind
of regulation has been all about
and uh you'll find that when the
fairness doctrine was abolished in 1968
in 1967 by a four to nothing vote of the
federal communications commission
almost instantly media changed and
conservative talk radio
came into the market because the
chilling
tax have been eliminated
and many people on the right came in
many people on the left air america and
so forth did not do well
in the ratings and came in came out came
back in came back
out but there are many other media
outlets that have
a variety of viewpoints and in fact the
entire rise of cable television
is also a free market phenomenon
cable television networks have no public
interest license
no authority from the government to
operate they enter and exit
under the dictates of open competition
and that's why you have ideological
competition
uh between an msnbc or a cnn
and a fox news it's why you have
actually neutral non-partisan platforms
like c-span and a host of other
kinds of competing content because there
is no public interest license
and there is no fairness doctrine
interestingly enough in 1987
leading conservatives were flat out
wrong about the fairness doctrine
they argued that conservatives needed
the fairness doctrine even as noted
that cbs and nbc and abc and the new
york times and all the major media
were biased to the left they actually
opposed the effort of the federal
communications to eliminate the policy
of the fairness doctrine
and indeed gov excuse me president
reagan
i'm from california so i guess that's a
slip of the tongue governor reagan
the the conservatives voted in large
measure
against reagan's repeal
excuse me reagan actually vetoed a
measure that would have made a statute
out of the fairness doctrine and made it
impossible for the fcc to eliminate it
gingrich voted against uh to overturn
the veto
uh jesse helms did likewise uh phyllis
schlafly reed irvine
they just turned out to be wrong some of
them have apologized because they saw
that this
of course opened up the world to more uh
political debate including from
conservatives
and it turns out the people on the left
in some cases including dan rather who
had been a newspaper journalist
obviously then went into
radio and television testified in favor
of the problems the censorship
implicit and uh profound that was
provided by this
chilling tax and ronald reagan himself a
former
broadcaster was very pro-first amendment
now it's important to remember the
history of the internet the first debate
was
should all the new platforms be wide
open and that was
sort of the cyber anarchist view in the
1990s there shouldn't be any editing all
the platforms should have exactly
everything people want to post all open
all the time there's one problem with
that
in fact there's several problems users
want
curation you don't want chaos you want
some editor to make things
sort of organized and reasonable and
within the realm of possibility for you
advertisers they want happy users that
spend a lot of time on websites
and um it's not the chaos is not
particularly good for them either of
course advertisers pay for a lot of this
conservatives if you want a website that
reflects your viewpoints
you want curation or moderation same on
the other side
in fact law enforcement has already
discussed wants a lot of curation wants
to eliminate some
potentially disruptive and in many cases
illegal activity and wants some rules
the problem is not all one or all the
other it's how to get the best possible
mix of course we want a lively debate we
want multiple viewpoints and diversity
and openness but on the other hand we
we want some moderation and how to get
there
um we've had a long going competition
between all kinds of walled gardens from
america online
way back in the 90s
which which collapsed because of
competition from the open internet
we've had the iphone be very
internalized google's much more open
with android in the in the
mobile space and then we've got wall
gardens
at myspace being replaced now by walled
gardens at facebook
by the walled garden we have a lot of
curation and a lot of control by the
network
this is all reflective of capitalist
enterprise
and the dynamism we see is a feature not
a bug
so it's not the end of history i want to
point out
that with all the big platforms
and the evident biases there are new
opportunities and ronald coast would be
the one to say
it is wrong to say this situation is
imperfect
and therefore a failure there are no
perfect solutions
we have to choose between complexities
of the market
complexities of the government we
actually have an infinite choice of
particular regimes and we want to look
for results the title of an interview
i did with coast several years ago
here's the link if you like
richard epstein summed it all up the
study of human institutions is always a
search
for the most tolerable imperfections
that's what we're after a cautionary
tale from jumping too quickly
the general data protection regulation
brought to us by the european union
effective may 25th
2008 is supposed to stop google and
facebook
from taking your private information and
selling it to advertisers
and yes all those click-throughs you
have on the internet now which
really are largely uh kicked into
effect uh from this gdpr
uh just a couple of years ago that did
slow
google and facebook down some watch if
we look at the
reach of the advertisers using these
platforms
but the smaller advertisers got hammered
compared to google and facebook in fact
this has been a tremendous protection
of the large incumbents in the internet
space
because the costs of complying with the
gdpr
are very large and favor the economies
of scale
right at the very top of the tech heat
so if you listen to mark zuckerberg in
his famous op-ed from a year ago
he says i believe we need a more active
role for governments and regulators
he's championing new regulation in this
space
that ought to give conservatives some
pause
and why why should we pause
because of a very simple fact facebook
doesn't need the government's help
to institute regulation in any of the
areas
it argues for facebook can do it all
it has every opportunity to institute
better privacy rules and more openness
or transparency
facebook is arguing for regulation to
constrain
the other platforms that's what they get
from a new regulatory regime i suggest
the competition
just might be much better again not
perfect
but better and you're going to like your
options over the long run
if we go that route it's a marketplace
out there
and conservatives and people who feel
that the existing structure are not
right they have the opportunity
to start different structures and of
course that's happening
many many of you may be interested may
be familiar with parlor which is a
straight out competitor to twitter and
facebook
and so many conservatives like dan
bongino
are striking deals and taking their
conversation there
it is a tough challenge for markets to
beat the economies of scale that are out
of course they're pursuing the same
economies of scale we'll see if they
have
100 billion dollar valuations in their
future
we should note that section 230 makes it
easier for the entrance
not harder that is to say if you impose
liability
on the internet platforms now you're
going to be sticking it to the entrance
and that's per
the ceo of parlor just the other day
okay yeah it's a tough challenge
uh for government to get things right
but uh it might be an easier challenge
for the market to get things right
and it's certainly a worthy project to
try
and i'll just point you in the direction
of hillsdale college
strength rejoices in challenge
thank you very much and as i say please
address
comments complaints groupons and bitcoin
to hazletaclemson.edu
have a great day thank you very much
you